y un grito de auxilio por la naturaleza
con un inmenso salvavidas extendido en
una selva de playa del carmen la ong
ambientalista internacional greenpeace
realizó una protesta pacífica para
frenar las obras del tramo 5 del llamado
tren maya que planea extenderse por la
riviera maya
a partir de las denuncias de ciudadanos
de activistas de habitantes de aquí de
la región pues vimos que se estaban
reanudando las obras del tramo 5 y es
por eso que greenpeace realizó trabajo
en campo para verificar que
efectivamente estaban ocurriendo y
reanudando las obras una de las
agrupaciones que denunció la
reactivación de las obras sin el permiso
judicial fue el movimiento ambientalista
sálvame del tren quien el pasado 5 de
julio publicó un comunicado invitando a
la población a detener el deterioro de
la selva que se enteren que el segundo
pulmón más importante de latinoamérica y
una de las reservas de agua dulce más
importantes del mundo si no exigimos de
forma colectiva proteger nuestro futuro
el tren maya ha sido uno de los
proyectos insignia del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador que
propuso invertir 10 mil millones de
dólares en alrededor de 1500 kilómetros
de vía férrea en los estados de chiapas
tabasco campeche yucatán y quintana roo
ubicados en el sureste del país esta es
la segunda vez que una organización
ambientalista internacional realiza una
protesta pacífica pidiendo que se
desmonten las construcciones en la selva